good morning welcome to this babera
overview and scrutiny committee i am
councillor mary mclaren and i am
chairing the meeting today
may i first of all remind you of some
domestic arrangements
please ensure that you maintain a social
distance from all other persons in the
chamber and in the social areas
please ensure that you wear a mask
unless you are speaking or if you are
unable to do so and that you use the
hand sanitizer and wipes provided
please maintain social distance at all
times during the meeting and during the
breaks
please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in use
that you do not interrupt other speakers
that if you're attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave
please ensure your mobile phones are on
silent or switched off
additionally we will be using e-voting
for this meeting on the modern.gov app
i would like to remind everyone present
at this meet that this meeting will be
broadcast live to the internet
and will be capable of repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exec sent to items
you make a representation to the meeting
you will be deemed by the council to
have consented to been filmed
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council
and to the possible use of those images
and sound recordings for webcasting and
or training purposes
the council
members of the public and the press
may
record film photograph or broadcast this
meeting
when the public and the press are not
lawfully excluded
um can i welcome to the meet in the
committee but in addition we have
members
and
officers present in attendance we have
councillor simon barrett cabinet member
for finance
councillor john osborne cabinet member
for housing
and emily ewell monitoring officer
officers attending are katherine steele
assistant director corporate resources
rebecca hewitt assistant manager
financial accountant
gavin fisk assistant director of housing
sean cole chancellor senior finance
business partner hra and gf revenue and
jenny smithers finance business partner
partner sorry about that
uh can i move to the agenda please
can i have apologies for absence and
substitutions
thank you chair we have apologies from
councillor catherine brandon
thank you
we to receive declarations of pecuniary
and non-pecuniary interests by members
nothing to declare
to receive notification of petitions in
accordance with the council's petition
scheme
none received thank you
questions by the public
none received
questions by counsellors none received
we now come to item six on the agenda
which is report number
b o s
forward slash twenty one forward slash
zero one
i would like to invite councillor simon
barrett
member for finance to introduce this
report thank you
good morning members and committee
this is the
report to you from
the finance officers
and myself
for the general fund budget for 2022-23
um
this is being brought for you so you can
look at it before it goes to
cabinet on the 7th of february
and
any observations that you wish to make
um will obviously be brought up at
cabins at that point
the um main points i'd like to just
raise that
in bringing this report to you we have
made
some slightly different assumptions from
the norm
in that
in the past
the budgets being presented
have been
fairly um the worst case scenario which
has
possibly resulted in
um you having to look at it
and make decisions or the council making
decisions which has resulted in maybe
service cuts which have then not
materialized when the out turn has come
so we've gone um and this also reflects
in the medium term financial strategy
within the report you'll see that
at
2025
i think you'll see there's a deficit of
2.3 million
which is part of that long-term uh plan
that
i don't wish to alarm you is what has
normally happened in every report
but when we actually come to the out
turns and reality so that actual the
fact normally means we have a
surplus rather than a deficit so
although it looks uh materially bad
we have on those
figures we have had to make assumptions
of
extra spending but not necessarily extra
income and that does obviously filter
through to that medium term because it
does get compounded up so it's not like
it's 2.3 million in any one year it's a
combination of those three years going
up to that point
so on with the basis of that what we
have done this year we have taken a
slightly less risk averse approach we
have asked the departmental the ads to
look at their costs uh not necessarily
put in the worst case scenario but look
at the more realistic based on their
previous spending history
this is um
allowed us i think to come forward with
a more accurate budget which is what we
all need to have so we can base our
decisions on fact rather than
fiction
there are a couple of points i think i
need to point out um with the um
assumptions that we are making we have
on the budget you're seeing at the
moment or coming forward we have assumed
a no percentage increase in council tax
so we started with that base point
that doesn't mean to say we will not
increase the budget that would be a
decision that the cabinet makes on the
7th of
february and that will be based on the
requirements and
what we need to spend going forward
but at the moment the budget is based on
that and we have got a balanced budget
with a zero increase
the other point i'd like to make
about reserves which is in your papers
in
in the past our reserves we have
basically had about a 12
reserve which is 1.2 million
that has been
pretty much standard throughout the last
few years
but um
we have never ever touched that reserve
even coming out of probably the biggest
public
service problem i would say in the
pandemic the reserve was not touched so
it does question whether we
really need to have the reserve in the
in the position that it is at 1.2
million so with discussions with um
uh the 151 officer catherine
because she's the one that ultimately
decides on this one whether it's sound
i think what we're going to propose
going forward is that we reduce that to
1 million pounds
and to free up the
200 000 pounds for use within the
community and
i think that's sensible bearing in mind
the
history that we've had with with that
amount of money just sitting there and
it's effectively dead money which we
have to have
um so i think we need to look at that
so on on that basis those are the the
areas that i think um i'd just like to
bring your attention to um
they it's a slightly different approach
i think we've got a we've got a nice
balanced budget going forward with a
showing a a surplus at the moment of um
and 403 thousand pounds
and uh i think that's a good position
for us
bearing in mind
what we've been through in the last two
years
so what i would like to do is just
obviously recommend you the uh
3.1 at the
recommendations which is to obviously
take that forward with any
recommendations that you may put forward
to cabinet on the 7th of february so
that's all i have to say thank you very
much
thank you councillor barrett
catherine are you going to uh
sorry and i forgot to mention the most
important thing is that uh catherine
will now present to you her slides
about the budget sorry about that
thank you chair
um yes we i know you've had the slightly
slides in advance of the meeting this
morning so i'm not proposing to talk to
them in great detail
but i thought it might be useful for the
committee if we just put them up perhaps
one slide at a time you know one one of
the major service areas and just see if
you did have any questions
for clarification as a result of having
seen the slides in advance
so
okay so the first one is communities and
well-being so
if it's okay with the chair i'll just
put each an area up and then just pause
and see if anybody has got any questions
right councillor barrett sorry to be so
quick
can i just check with you on on that
captain because it's quite a large
figure we see for leisure 259k
um
as we move to the green tariff
um but but it sounds cost neutral in a
way if you're being reimbursed by abby
croft but then we fund abby croft
so is that's a one-off that's the cost
of moving to a green tariff that's it
so yes this is a change from how we've
done it previously
because you're right we fund abbycroft
to run the leisure services for us in
baber so we pay them a management fee
the management fee stays there so that's
still still as it has always been but
this changes in terms of their utilities
so their gas and their electricity
normally they would enter into the
contract so they would pay all of their
utility bills and we would have nothing
to do with it
the change that's happening this year is
we've entered into the contract to
enable us as the council to to gain um
the carbon reduction uh because the
contract being with an external provider
we couldn't do that but it's obviously
we're investing an awful lot of money
into our leisure
assets to be able to have a carbon
reduction in terms of their impact
so we're entered into the contract for
the gas and electricity so we are making
the payments
but we are being fully reimbursed by
abby croft
so if you think of it perhaps in terms
of next financial year the management
fee will still be there so we still pay
that to abby croft
we will also be paying out the gas and
the electricity charges but we will be
getting income back from abby croft so
in terms of this slide you'll see this
the large numbers under the other
expenses column so that's where we're
going to be paying out the money to the
for the gas and electricity
and then the income coming back under
the income column so one they've both
gone up if you like one's gone up as a
cost and one's gone up as an income and
they balance each other off
in terms of the leisure line as a whole
i just like to ask because i had a
question about that as well
um is this a good
is this a good agreement for us
it is in terms of us trying to reach our
ambition of being carbon neutral
because obviously the leisure services
are there because as a council we're
wanting them to be run
so
if we can't claim that we're reducing
our carbon impact unless we we enter
into these green tariffs on behalf of
abby croft so i say it's it's cost
neutral in terms of the council but it
also gives us that ability to if you
like claim the fact that we are reducing
our carbon footprint and the services
that we ask others to run on our behalf
is also you know reducing the carbon
footprint
thank you catherine are there any more
questions for catherine on this
particular
council of gold
can i just ask the ccd cctv costs that
are offset by contribution um i think
you've answered it catherine but it
might be nice to have administered um is
it a permanent contribution or was it
one-off
that is permanent so yeah that's an
ongoing contribution to cover the
running costs of the cctv
okay so it'll be regular year on years
any more questions from
members
so the next one we've got is the the
housing area
and just to be clear this is the general
fund housing area not the housing stock
obviously we've got the next report on
your agenda which looks at the the
council housing
so again i'll just pause and see if
there are any questions
questions from members
okay so the next one is economic
development and regeneration so again
i'll just pause
members
committee
oh catherine does that come into this
i know it's it's in the
sorry
uh sorry uh i had one about bellevue
does that would that
fit in with this at this point or shall
i ask it separately
it depends what aspect of bellevue
because the actual property um i think
the maintenance costs it within assets
and investments so it depends what
the aspect is the question i had
um was about the refurbishment which was
two million pounds
and i was just wondering
that be an initial outlay of money what
would be perhaps the ongoing maintenance
cost of that
i think the two million pounds was set
aside
for the
capital programme in terms of the
access to the park
it wasn't really put aside for the
ongoing
maintenance of the building or the park
so the capital that was there
as a
as a top up really because obviously
there's a capital receipt coming into
the council the sale of the land if that
goes ahead and also the sale of bellevue
house to the developer and the the
the capital receipt plus this 2 million
would be sufficient for us to redevelop
the um uh
park entrance and cafe and upgrade some
of the facilities so i think that was
what was that was what that was put in
for
but
but presumably there will be then so i
mean that's a one-off thing isn't it
there would be
well it's in the capital programme okay
thank you
i was saying i probably could just add
to that if there are any ongoing costs
that the council will be liable for then
they they would sit within the assets
and investments area of the of the
budget
okay so moving on to the environment uh
consciousness is an area that has got a
few different service areas in it so
again i will pause for questions
any questions
counselor barrett
i think it
sorry
it's interesting to note that uh i think
i've noticed uh the
costs for eid verde
or the environment
that i'd rarely used to carry out and
now coming back in-house is expected not
to
increase costs
which seems curious um
um as to you know how how we've achieved
that
um
does that include all your vehicle
uh costs that will accrue in the future
yes obviously the the running costs of
the vehicles are included in the budget
so
all the employees the supplies and
service transport costs they are all now
built into the budget
for baber for next financial year now
that that service has been brought back
in house
i think obviously the corporate manager
for this area he's been able to take the
opportunity of this service coming back
in-house to look at how it operates
alongside the service that has been
in-house for a number of years for
mid-suffolk so i'm sure there's probably
a few economies there that he could
generate from having both operating
in-house and hence you're not seeing any
increase overall in terms of the the
budget being proposed for next year
osborne
thank you madam jim
um
many thanks for all your hard work over
the past months to both councillor
barrett
and officers to get us to this stage not
an easy task
my question is i understand
that there is more than
possible that the government will
request councils
to not charge for collection of garden
waste and to also introduce the
collection of food waste and glass
currently i believe that the cost of the
garden waste is um 684 k
per annum and the income over a million
if introduced in 2223 financial year
the cost of the council will be vast i
apologize if i've missed
in this report from
5.15
but
has this been taken into consideration
in the budget
the
changes i believe are proposed from
april 23 so not in april 22 but the
following financial year so there isn't
any change built into the budget for
next financial year
and our understanding obviously these
things will play out over the next year
is the government are saying that they
would fund the change
to local authorities obviously we would
have to see how that actually comes
about and plays out over the next year
but the impact of
having to do extra collections or not be
able to charge for certain collections
obviously comes with the cost but the
government at the moment is giving
assurances to councils that it would
fund that that change which it's
requiring us to do nationally so let's
say nothing in next year's budget
because it it's scheduled to come in
from april 23 but he's obviously
something that would need to be
looked at in setting your 23-24 budget
yes thank you very much for that
katherine but
obviously
i would be
very sort of
concerned
if this sets the hair running for our
budgets in the future
uh osborne
any more question
i've got a question catherine and it's
about the
the fleet and the money's expended on
the purchase of the new fleet
um i understand
that the
there's going to be a new environment
bill which will might alter
collections of waste of various kinds
is that built into the
has that been built into the budget
we have in the capital programme for the
environment area we have got money in
there for replacing the fleet for 2223
or the majority of the fleet
um i think it's a moving target so i
think the corporate manager for that
area is sort of he's got a watching
brief in terms of
what the vehicles might need to be for
the future so i think the vehicles are
coming to the end of their current life
but say the corporate manager i think is
being cautious in terms of not
committing too early before we know
exactly what those changes are and i
know he is looking at different options
you know looking at perhaps leasing
vehicles as opposed to purchasing
vehicles to perhaps give us the
flexibility to be able to respond to
those changes that come across so yes
it's definitely been considered as part
of the budget proposals
okay
and if you look in your appendix b uh
you'll see the replacement refuse
freighter joint scheme that's that's
there so it's quite a big figure
um
which is on an ongoing program because
we don't they don't just replace they
place them as a win so it's on a cycle
i didn't realize you see that um
it was only listening to something else
that i realized that there was
some new rules that might come out that
might affect the actual specification
of the of the fleet
thank you very much
any more questions for this the
environment
okay so moving on to customers digital
transformation and improvements and
again i'll pause if there any questions
councilor barrett
thank you um
on this slide catherine can you um can
you just um look at um
it talks about customer digital
transformation
i can't
i can't quite locate where the sudbury
town council
offset by savings on exit from the
contract
so
is is that
the the cost has remained below what the
contract used to cost with suffer with
sudbury town council
yes i believe there has been a small
reduction in the costs overall so
the cost of running what baber is doing
now in terms of sudbury compared to what
sudbury town council used to run i
believe there is a small reduction in
that service cost overall
we've got the strategic policy increase
which is
the significant figure up there before
us um
but that
you've taken over you've taken some
costs over from another area haven't you
to to offset so that's your is that your
income
coming into that
um that area
i think i think i saw 120 from lawn
governance is that 120 going from law
and governance into that
fund
it's it's going into this line but not
through the 110 so
under the employees heading you've got a
mixture of things in there so the 286
000 figure so you've got some money
that's coming across from from law and
governance i think it's just over a
hundred thousand pounds off the top of
my head but then that's being
supplemented by
additional resources that we need to
bring into this particular area so it's
a combination
and 110 that you were just asking about
in the movement in reserves column we
are using some reserves to pay for some
of that additional resource in
2223 so
it brings down the impact on the budget
overall by using the reserves
so this is a new team that we're putting
together with a combination of resources
from elsewhere in the organization that
are doing some of the things we want to
sort of centralize and bring together
and
do better so the new outcomes framework
that was recently approved by cabinet
we need the resources to be able to
manage and monitor all of that and in
terms of our digital transformation and
we need staff to be able to drive
through a package of projects to look at
how we become
efficient in terms of our processes and
sort our policy area as well and that
look ahead and what's coming out of the
government and the impact that it's
likely to have on the council so it's
sort of trying to bring together bits
and pieces that are happening across the
organization into one new central
function for for next financial year
just a a comment really um that perhaps
this is an area for us to pick up in the
future because it's such a a huge cost
um for the for the the um
council to undertake and and put
a lot of resources and i expect quite
senior people um in that team to bring
about those changes i think we might
want to understand that we are seeing
that driving through improvements for
our residents and not just bringing
causing a sort of a reshuffling
internally that you know can sometimes
be difficult to actually translate that
into actual actions uh
that change change the way we serve the
public
so
can we pick that up in our
recommendations later on uh chair thank
you thank you councillor barrett in fact
that was one of my on my list
on how this
um sounds very exciting and very
proactive but how it's going to be
monitored
and yes we'd like to pick that up later
thank you councillor
thank you chair um
i see that that there is a 475 000
budgeted for ict
to cover increase suffolk county council
contract and but then year on year it
falls away in successive years is there
any reason for that fall away
and page 23
under ict and customer there
so by the time we get to the 25-26
forecast it's dropped right away to 150
000.
this is the capital investment programme
for ict
so this is what we think we need to
invest in new software or new systems to
be able to change the way we work
so
the figure is certainly higher in 20 to
23
because we're looking to replace the
finance system so that's once or
significant system that we we're needing
to replace
so that's why we've got more money in
the early years
we usually tend to have an annual figure
of the hundred and fifty thousand pounds
but there are one or two extra things in
the early years that have increased
increased that figure so say this is the
actual capital program and enabled us to
invest and then obviously to save in
terms of how we operate
thank you
questions
say corporate resources is is the next
one so again just pause if there are any
questions i know this is a complicated
area because there's quite a few central
things that go through the finance
budget so as i will just pause if there
are any questions
okay the next one is a law and
governance so again i'll just pause and
see if any questions
say this is the area where some of those
uh staffing resources have been moved
from
so under the
governance and civic office line you'll
see that
minus the the figure in brackets of 120
000 under the employees so that's where
the staffing is being transferred across
to that new team we were just talking
about strategic policy and performance
so again i'll just pause if there any
other questions on that one
okay so assets and investments is the
next one
again i'll pause there
actually any questions
no
move on
okay
just i say just two more to go so uh
planning and building control is the the
next one so again just pause
all
right thank you um
where you have
um the uh line chief planning office
officer
is that all the services that come under
the control of that chief planning
officer
yes it is so it is um
development management enforcement and
heritage so they all sit within within
that line
and just to to
on the the second bullet point you've
referred to legal costs um
um
and uh 40k
and that does that cover all our
enforcement and appeals throughout
throughout an average year then because
we seem to have many challenges
yes um it's it this budget is intended
to cover those costs obviously it's
difficult to predict you know what is
going to happen in a particular year but
just sort of using experience of
previous years
um there may be a budget in there
already i'm not 100 sure whether there
is a budget and it's being supplemented
for next year but yes it is it is meant
to to cover the the various level of
appeals and where we might need to seek
legal advice and obviously incur the
costs as a result of that
any more questions council about it
councillor
um
it's on the um planning fee thing really
income um but at point 4.5 on the report
we had
says there are several variants
variances which contribute to the
overall position
that are detailed in the report but two
key factors of planning application
income continues to exceed the budget
and i just wondered
um
whether the assumption in terms of the
figures whether
why are we surprised that the income
continues to exceed the budget does that
make sense fit to do it once
is is understandable but fit to continue
to exceed would we not choose to put a
higher figure in the budget
yes thank you a very good question and
that is what we are doing for next
financial year so
on this line um in terms of the the
slide
let me just remind myself
we are
increasing the planning fee income next
year so we are increasing that budget
because we have seen that trend over
recent times thank you
any more questions
okay and the last one is the senior
leadership team so again just pause
counselor barrett oh yes may i um thank
you jeff um
you've given uh
the figure of 41k as the
potential increase
so would that be for a whole year or
costs or
what
how has that broken down
yes it's been allowed for for the whole
financial year so it's a year's cost and
it's a it's a combination of the
increase
from the annual pay award and any
incremental progression
within the the team but also there's the
allowance in there as the as the slide
says uh for the senior pay review so
should that be approved at some point
then we have got the allowance within
the budget to be able to pay for it for
next year so so there's sort of a
combination of two factors in there
that's driving that increase that you're
seeing
that's another point with the overall
budget the um problem that we have is
that we with the annual settlement for
the wages that hasn't been agreed yet uh
but we have actually put in a two
percent increase for all staff whether
that actually is two percent or 2.5 that
will impact the budget um it could be
that at the moment i think it's settled
on 1.75 which is what's on offer so it's
below what we put in but again we're
we're certainly um as it's a national
settlement we we can't obviously get
accurate any more than we have so we've
had to put in a figure which we feel is
reasonable for the time which is two
percent
and that's on the overall staffing
levels
i suppose
uh a little query for me is the um
the calculation that you've made on the
senior leaders pay is
dependent on
the
um the structure of the
the new pay award
um because that's
we don't have that at the moment
has that been structured
rather as the
proposal was in the autumn term
as based on that
yes it has been i know there are ongoing
discussions about it but we haven't got
a final settled position you know final
proposal coming forward so at the moment
it is based on what was previously put
thank forward any more questions
on that particular
topic
okay i think we've come to the end of
the presentation then so i think that
can be can be taken off the screen and
then happy to answer any other questions
that the committee have got on the rest
of the paper thank you
thank you
committee members have we got some more
questions
yes councillor gold
um do you want all of mine and then all
of council osborne's and then
yeah
okay
um
my
first question is on page eight
and the bullet points
um
that come attached to
4.10 in the report
my question's on the final one really
reduced climate change and biodiversity
impact is one of the overarching
principles um
but then i'm a bit concerned about
that the last three words there were
financially viable
and i just wondered whether
perhaps a more appropriate assumption in
view of climate change
and the fact that we have declared a
climate emergency might be for us to
decide what we need to do
and then to find the finance
rather than financing
with the bit that we've got left
i i put that piece in because i felt it
was not correct just to
have climate emergency has been declared
i'm not quite sure what that has and how
it
district council can impact the climate
emergency
so it needs to be thought through and
costed to make sure there is a benefit
so where we can and where we have
improved and made climate changes in
terms of
the fueling of our waste vehicles is one
thing we can actually materially and
have a tangible benefit to
then that's great and that was costed it
has cost us more money because obviously
there's capital so we take the balance
that the the benefits in climate change
outweigh the financial situation i think
it's just a case of just being sensible
because you can't just be irresponsible
and say we will do a certain action
which actually has a real in financial
impact on the council and ultimately our
residents with very little green or um
carbon zero benefit so i think it's just
prudent to put that in where it is
financially it's not saying we're not
doing it it's just that we need to
assess it
make sure that it is um
worth us doing it for the benefit
because i think there's a big balance
there of where and there's a danger of
just saying we're going green
but the cost might be prohibitive and it
might have more have a harder impact on
our residents bearing in mind there's
already quite a lot of cost pressures
that they're already facing so i think
it's just it's just to make sure that we
look at it in a fine in the financial
round as well as the the net carbon zero
issue which obviously we want to go to
and that's what we've stated but i think
we need to just be sensible in our
approach so that's that's the only
reason i put that in because i think it
just makes sense that we balance
what we can achieve as a district
council which is limited but when we do
it it is financially viable for us and
for our residents i hope that answers
that jane
thank you council about yes um certainly
financial um sensibility and prudence is
is to be applauded and i wouldn't um i
wouldn't deny that um
and
it's a good thing that the fleet has
been um decarbonized uh i think one of
the most obvious hits though in terms of
um of our carbon reduction
is the retrofitting of the housing stock
that we've got which is hugely expensive
isn't it and one of my other questions
was going to be um that there's actually
um let me just see if i can find it
it'll probably come in that probably
needs to come in the hra discussion yes
yes absolutely um so that that would be
an obvious hit and and for that budget
perhaps i i realize that but thank you
cats about my next question is
um page 9 4.17
the sentence that starts about halfway
down that paragraph it traditionally
represents about 10 percent of the net
budget but as it was not used during the
curvy 19 pandemic this could be reviewed
my question is it could be reviewed will
it be
well i did mention it in my opening
remarks so that is the what i was
referring to basically we've had um uh
in the reserve of 1.2 million which we
set aside as our reserve
for the sort of i mean it's sort of what
they call the rainy day
reserve when uh
council is expected to find something
that it hasn't got budget which is
an additional cost that comes to it
um through
through an emergency type situation
well we've always sat there for the last
10 years probably with 1.2 million
sitting that budget has never been
touched and effectively it is dead money
um
you don't have to have um this level of
budget i mean i think the minimum that
the government will accept is about five
percent
um but on discussing it with um
catherine who feels that that would be
far too low
and i tend to agree with her because if
if it was a really big emergency then we
wouldn't have it but then if it was that
big an emergency central government me
in anyway so um i i tend to think that
what we need to do is have a more of a
sense of a balanced approach and bearing
in mind mid suffolk don't have that
amount set aside in their budget so
we're really aligning ourselves more to
them not that's the case but it's to
have a 10 budget bearing in mind our
overall budget is roughly 10
million so if we have the million there
that frees up effectively the 200 000 i
mentioned earlier which we can put to
the use of our residents and and very
close to your heart if it meant some
green initiatives we could use it for
that so um i mean that that's the sort
of uh area which i think would be
sensible and that's what we're
suggesting um and it is something that
uh i think we need
it's it's something that needs to be
looked at we we must be irresponsible
with it but i think because we're
looking at it and if you look at over
the period of time we certainly have
never touched it we haven't touched it
in the last two years which would
probably be the most
likely area to have used it
so it probably is too big for what we
actually require and that's why we're
looking to reduce that to one million
pounds and and free up the 200 000.
so i i suppose the answer to my question
is that yes it's not that it could be
reviewed but it is being reviewed which
is what you say
always
i mean uh yeah okay and 4.18
second first bullet point there changes
to the this is cifco isn't it really um
changes to the public works loan board
lending criteria to exclude the ability
to borrow to invest in commercial
property
just to keep an eye on cifco
and we are i'm sure but just to check
that we are keeping an eye on cifco uh
well sifko
due to these changes in the way that the
government has
brought forward
basically means that we are not in a
position where we could go and uh
increase the amount of uh capital that
we would put into cifco
for that particular reason so cifco is
now set
and is generating its income which is as
as per the budget it's slightly below
there's slight pressures on that but
overall it's performing reasonably well
and it's performing within the
tolerances that we had initially
projected so i think there's
it's doing what it was set up to do
which is good uh but we can't expand it
and we probably we can't expand it
because the government won't allow us to
with that work yeah
and we will of course um scrutinize
cifco at the appropriate time to
scrutinize civco won't we um
bullet point 4.22
this is to do with the cpi isn't it
dropping significantly
expected to hit a peak in the next few
months before it turned to its target
although economic commentators are
increasingly challenging that assumption
so my question would be that we are
again keeping an eye on that aren't we
so that when that assumption um becomes
an incorrect one that we're ahead of
that game yeah we're keeping an eye on
it it has more significance in the hra
account because that's where we
determine how we uh put our council
rents up
uh the the situation according to the
bank of england this is a temporary
brick um mainly caused by the uh rather
high fuel price inflation that we've
seen
um and hopefully that will stabilize and
bring it back down to a more reasonable
level
and obviously uh the reasonable level
should be two percent which is where the
bank of england governor has to right to
the chance to say we've got a problem um
so uh um i i would assume that that will
get down to a
probably more reasonable level but
obviously we do have to take this into
account because it not only affects
our budget but it affects where we
are charging rates as well so that's
something we will obviously keep an eye
on
thank you i think that's all of mine
chair thank you thank you thank you
councillor
chair if i could just answer that just a
little bit more to say that in the
future years so in 2223
our managers have managed to absorb most
of the inflation that they could see
coming through but for the years beyond
22-23 we've currently got a 2 allowance
built into those budgets obviously we
would need to keep that under review
over the coming months as we go into
building the budget for 23.24 to see if
two percent is enough or whether it has
stayed above that level but we have got
that allowance built in at the moment
lovely thank you
councillor barrett if i may please thank
you
um
we just revisiting the
issue about the
reduction to a million in in your
reserves
um i presume that at the moment you earn
interest on on those reserves
and that goes back into your general
fund
um that will reduce if your
if your uh
amount on deposit is reduced has that
been also calculated and
it is actually going to be quite a small
change at the margin so we haven't
changed to change the assumptions in
terms of the interest
we have some
long
long-term pooled investment funds
where we have spare cash that are
invested in but i would see this small
change of 200 000 just being wrapped up
in our day-to-day
cash flow activities
um and obviously we make an assumption
as to the the level of interest and i
mean the level of the interest rate i
mean the base rate is still very low at
the moment so you get very little
interest on that anyway so i think we
are talking very much at the margin in
terms of that change of the the 200 000.
i guess really um
i was going to
just
ask a little bit about pensions um
yes councilman
and the position
that you're in at the moment with um
the catch-up
um that you're you're doing at the
moment for your pension fund
so you know we've i know we've discussed
it um in in our previous um meeting
but um can you just um
you know give us that explanation of
what
where we are with the pension fund and
and um
and what sort of future impact there
might be on that how sure are you that
you've got got that figure right now
i i just well basically the pension fund
at the moment we're it's a tri-annual
um assessment so it's reviewed every
three years
um and at the moment i think i'm right
in saying that our ex we have we have to
pay an extra contribution to top it up
um and i think we've got a review in
march this year
22 march 22
march 22
where that will be reviewed again
bearing in mind that the stock market
has gone up significantly since the last
review
um it will be interesting to see whether
we are required to still keep putting
extra money in to keep the fund at its
required value but i think catherine's
probably got more detail on that than i
have but that's just a general overview
yeah just just to pick up the the actual
question you were asking about yes we
have had to make an adjustment in next
year's budget to make sure that our
contribution is at the right level um we
have been slightly under contributing
based on the number of employees and
as councillor barrett just mentioned
that sort of deficit position so when we
looked at the whole we weren't quite
contributing enough each year so we have
corrected that
but offsetting that is the outcome of
the last triennial valuation so at the
last valuation the fund had increased in
its value so it meant we could
reduce by one percent each year for the
three years following that that last
valuation so although we've had to
increase our
commitment in terms of that base
position and getting it right
we have also been able to drop it
slightly because of that one percent
reduction so you'll see in the reports
there's actually a net increase of of
just 22 000 overall when we've looked at
those two elements together
so say there's those two factors at play
in in terms of the budget being proposed
for next
i year questions about the um
the building
services but are we we'll do that at our
hra
sorry will we do that under a separate
hra heading yeah
thank you councillor barrett councillor
osborne do you have any questions
thank you madam chairman
no i'm i'm very impressed with our lady
councillors here today they've asked
questions that i've probably had i'm
going to ask myself but
it's uh
it's very much appreciated the questions
they asked and i found that and
particularly the answers given by
councillor barrett and uh
and katherine thank you
i have actually got two questions
that's the only thing about being the
chairman is it could go to the last
um given the that the most recent uh
report by the institute of fiscal
studies
uh stated that councils had
overestimated their expenditure for
coving management by about 50 percent
actually
and i think the report sort of said
about councils being awash with extra
money and
how much do we have in in that fund that
we were allocated during covidon um
how do we see that
continuing
um
the amount we've got in balance is seven
hundred
seven hundred and two thousand there
the total amount that we had for coving
which was quite considerable but the the
actual balance we've got i mean that's
not to say that that won't be spent and
it's been put in a reserve account to be
actually used against any future uh
spending that we might have i think
that's right
yeah yeah
so um yeah i wouldn't say we were awash
um
but
certainly the government's support was
adequate for the expenditure that we
that we actually did actually have to
put out so i think that that was um
that's covered um
but to say we're awash some councils
might be um
i think we've covered ourselves i think
i was only quoting what i'd i mean i
wasn't suggesting for a minute we might
be awash with extra funds but does that
have to eventually be repaid to the
government or
no we don't
there is no sort of if you like strings
attached to when the grant was given to
us it was given by the government to
assist local authorities with with the
coveted response
and just to say i think we are still
seeing the impact of it and we're not
likely to get any more money from the
government now so i think the money that
we have still got in reserve i think is
probably going to still be required for
some of our response depending on you
know what happens over coming months i
mean we are using some of it in this
financial year and i can see some of
that impact still continuing into next
year so i think what we have got left
you know i think we need to be honest to
be able to to get us through a bit a bit
longer so although the government gave
us all that money
in quite a short period of time really
it was sort of over a 15-month period i
think the impact and our call on that
money is going to be over a longer
period of time
thank you and i've got one more question
um and this came because
these papers are public
um i just want cl
clarification on the capital fund
and in the capital fund it's 12.3
million pounds
um
i think i i think i would welcome a
clarification of of what that actually
means
uh in terms of where the money is or
how it's
managed
one of the good
graphs that we've got is the pie chart
which is quite good
um in the latest report this is a new uh
way of
delivering a visual of how it is so i
think if you look at the pie chart um
one of the big problems with the capital
programme not the problem is that we
seem to have an inability to spend what
we've allocated
um i'm hoping that we will get around to
spending that i mean nine thousand three
hundred nine thousand three hundred
million was brought forth from last year
and probably from the previous year as
well
where there are projects that are
stalled that we've put money in
and those projects have not gone ahead i
mean obviously covet has restricted some
of them but they have definitely stalled
and have not gone ahead
because we've been looking at other
things
though what i would like to see is those
projects um delivered
which would mean that you don't have
that 12 million in the capital i mean
obviously some of those are ring fence
which we know
but there's like 6.3 million pounds
there for
regeneration fund uh which is put in for
hamilton road i think
which i'm looking forward to seeing that
go forward there's two million which you
already mentioned previously which was
the
bellevue there was also another three
million for the um uh
ox um
headquarters building
so you've got that and that's your sort
of nine million uh
and those projects which have been in
for some time and they really we need to
get them out and spend
uh the also the the the other thing that
is worth noting when you look at your
median term financial strategy that
those projects are costed in the ongoing
not the total amount
i mean those projects are in the
accounts they're not
it's not we haven't got that money it's
money that we will borrow from the
public versus loan board etc so what we
do in the budget i think there's an
element or a percentage of that assumed
borrowing goes into the medium-term
financial strategy but of course there
is no up the other side of that in terms
of income that we would get so that's
why it always looks slightly worse well
it looks quite a lot worse actually so i
think what we need to do is take that
into account when you look at your
medium-term financial strategy because
we're assuming there's a level of spend
or requirement of the capital there so i
think what
what we need to do is um as a council we
need to get on and spend the money and
deliver the projects that we've got
allocated within there and that would
obviously get rid of that balance which
is sitting there and being brought
forward every year
and catherine i'm sure you've got
something to say on that
just in terms of
i think the chair was perhaps just
asking about the status of of those
budgets i mean the money i think i think
you're referring to that the 12 million
that we're looking to potentially bring
forward from the current financial year
into next year
just to say it's it's a budget we
haven't actually got the cash sitting in
the bank it's as councillor barrett said
it's an approval to be able to borrow to
do something but until we actually spend
the money on a project then
that's when we borrow the money to get
the cash to be able to do that so it's
not sitting in a bank account anywhere
at this point in time
thank you catherine because that is
actually what people could assume
in reading the report and it just
clarifies that it's not actually
in an account that's very helpful thank
you very much
any more questions
councillor osborne
thank you madam chair i don't know if
this is a applicable tool
for what we've been discussing but
i see we've got um monies in the
estimated reserve balances for the joint
local
a
plan
thousand i'll take it that is split
between the two councils however
um i'm concerned about the way that the
joint local plan is going at the moment
and would we
have to take out more than has been
estimated please thank you
the hundred thousand pounds is just
babers so um we have actually both
councils have actually got an allocation
of a hundred thousand pounds
um there are some additional costs that
are going to be incurred in
22-23 because of you know the position
we're in but we will be drawing down i
don't believe that they exceed what
you've got in reserve i think we have
actually
budgeted to take out the hundred
thousand pounds but i think that does
balance the costs that we think and
might actually be more than in the end i
think we're being quite cautious in
terms of of what we might need to spend
still
thank you catherine
is that it counselor
counselor barrett you had a question
thank you um
there's that there's a reference in in
the papers to the enterprise zone and
the grant of 216 000 which is really
good news for that area
is that the only area that we could have
applied for or obtained an enterprise
zone grant it seems you know
i'm surprised there's no other areas
within our district that
that would fall into that sort of
category considering we've got um
worsted as the food enterprise zone i
think was talked about in the past
i have to say i'm not an expert on
enterprise zones but you're right and
this is the spartan site in in weber is
the only one that is designated as an
enterprise zone
so i'm not an expert so i don't know
exactly what the conditions are that you
know makes them worthwhile and yes you
have got the food enterprise zone as
well yes
and the benefit that that gives to the
council is that when you have got a
designated enterprise zone obviously the
businesses that go into that enterprise
zone
get a reduction in their business rates
for a period of time but it also enables
local councils like ourselves we
actually get to retain more of the
business rates obviously we don't
collect it from the businesses because
they're getting a reduction but the
government pays us the rates that we we
aren't able to collect but we get to
keep a hundred percent in terms of an
enterprise zone so they are they are
financially good news in terms of a
council but i say apologies i don't
quite know the intricacies of enterprise
zones to know whether you would have
anywhere else necessarily in the
district that would
be useful to you know to explore
no questions counsel about any more
questions
counselor gold
can i just ask about the risk management
page 17
[Music]
the first risk description which is to
do with government funding not keeping
pace with demand
it's the only risk
likelihood that is scored as high as
probable
and it's the only impact that scored a
three as far as bad
and yet
my question is are the mitigation
measures
for that high score in the risk
management sufficient are they robust
enough
well you'll be pleased to know
that the government did better than we
thought
so the settlement figure that we got was
higher than we'd put in the original
budget
so when we were preparing the initial
budget the um there was a whole category
that we'd left out which equated 146 000
pounds which is a rural settlement
new services which we had we assumed
wasn't going to get we had that and then
the overall session was better so
although that was i mean that is a high
risk because obviously if we don't get
the money then we we are really
searching for where we're going to have
to make savings and things like that
actually in reality what happened um we
had more money come in
than we had anticipated which is why
we're in quite a nice position going
forward so um
the upshot levels
yes it's a risk it's a big risk if we
don't get it if we get it then that risk
is negated totally
yes
as you say counts about it it's it's a
high risk likelihood it's called three
um with an impact of three so i'm just
wondering then does the likelihood as
you've got more information does the
likelihood need to drop to two perhaps
um
well i don't do risk management um i
will pass that conveniently over to
catherine because she probably got a
better understanding of that risk
where it sits
i think definitely in terms of the 22-23
budget i think that probably could
reduce to a two now that we've had the
provisional settlement information from
from the government and has given us
that assurance i think it does continue
to be a risk into the future because as
part of the 2223 settlement the
government have indicated that the
increase for next year
that's not going to happen again in the
future so they have sort of been
indicating that any pressures that we've
got in our budgets moving forward we've
got to try and fund that within our own
resources and
cancel taxes the one that gets mentioned
by the government you know if they're
not going to give further grants so yes
i think you're right i think it could
come down now for 22 23 and then we'd
need to assess again for 23 24 and where
where we're at
yes um either that or the mitigation
measures need to be a bit more robust
because with a um a three likelihood and
a three impact a bad impact just to
continue to lobby government doesn't
seem to be a robust enough mitigation
for that risk
thank you
thank you
council
thank you very chairman can i just
say that the assurance that
catherine has given us today
has been well in excess of other other
budget meetings that i've attended to
over the years and we always seem to
have
not knowing what we were going to get in
so
this is a very positive reaction thank
you catherine
any more questions from the
committee members
um
well that comes to the end of our
questions can i just thank um catherine
um and
[Music]
her team and councillor barrett for all
the hard work that has been put into the
report
i think we've benefited greatly by the
information you've shared with us and we
just want to thank you all very much for
all that hard work
thank you mom
i endorse exactly what you've said and
i'm sure all the other members are
exactly the same opinion um may i just
ask for a short break
shall we get to hr can we
thank you
members we've
asked a lot of questions we now
go into debate
would somebody like to open the debate
counselor barrett
you saw my hand waiver
oh um
well
i think um i think what we've been able
to establish is the the budget is um
very comprehensive
um
[Music]
anticipation of all future costs and uh
it's been very reassuring to hear
through all those responses
um
one area
that um
that i
would like to have
seen i suppose um
this is a completely new idea
that i haven't asked about previously
but
i've raised it with the chief executive
um and the leader is the
potential sort of um outlining a
a figure
for staff costs that you the council
couldn't exceed
based on the percentage of income
so that would provide flexibility
to the council so that they can up or
down it according to what their income
is so it wouldn't be
wouldn't be limited um so i don't know
what fellow my fellow
members feel about that and whether that
could be something they they want to to
see
in future years
i'm not in time for this this budget but
um
just to just uh
just an idea i wanted to float
can't counselor gold
yeah have i understood that correctly
councillor barrett um a set a set figure
in future budgets for staff costs
yes in terms of percentage of income
so tell us a percentage of income that
could not be exceeded
without without coming back to full
council anyway
i wonder whether that would tie
the finance
committee's hands too much
well i think it it's it would have
complete flexibility for the chief
executive to appoint staff as and when
as as to where they wanted to deploy
them
how what grades they wanted to deploy
them as long as it was within a certain
figure um and if if they wanted to a
point above that they would have to come
back and get consent from cabinet or
whatever the system was at the time
i don't know what i think about that
i'd have to think about it a bit more
councillor osborne do you um
do you wish to make a comment on that
well i tend to agree with
cancer gould here
it's it's an area that
do you really want to go down
the hr route on something like this i i
don't think it's quite honestly worth it
i think the budget has been
fairly explained and if they keep to the
way it is at the moment i think
i think it's ideal
um
that's just it's it's a very um
i'm floating an idea there so i i
i realize that is a new concept for
everyone to to to think about so
i'm happy not to pursue that
can i i think in debate we're supposed
to speak for three minutes and that's it
isn't it really are you okay for me to
well no carry on yeah i think we can be
invincible
it's not many of us actually
it kind of opens the door potentially
and i'm absolutely certain this isn't
the case at the moment but worst case
scenario it opens the door for some
staff to be paid
as long as it's within that ceiling of
the budget that's been allowed for some
staff to be paid excessively
and other staff to be paid
not a remuneration that is appropriate
for their for their role
perhaps i think the other counselor
barrett wished to say something thank
you
i i think i can see the concept
basically what you're doing is you're
saying within within the budget you have
a total amount of spend that the chief
exec would be able to spend on on his
staffing costs so really the owners
would be on the chief exec if you set a
maximum amount based on your income then
he would have to
uh
increase or decrease his staffing costs
in line with that budget
it could have problems because through
no fault of the council you could get a
reduction in the income from the central
government
which has no reflection on the uh
outcomes that we want so i can see the
theory
um if we were in total charge of our
income
and we were totally responsible for our
income then that would be sensible but
bear in mind as was pointed out earlier
as councillor cool pointed out when
we're saying about the
where we get the money from central
government and we and the risk factor
there
i think
you do have an element of risk that if
central government reduced their grant
um
we would we would probably have to
reduce staffing costs anyway because the
grant would be reduced but it would put
extra pressure on that so i can see
there's there's an advantage and a
disadvantage i can see from a from a uh
overall
scrutiny of the
overall wages cost if that's what you're
looking to put a cap on and then stop
for the chief exec to work within that
area
i can see that that does work but also
there's other pressures if it's based on
income maybe it needs to be something a
little less just on income
maybe the overall budget of the council
because you're just based on income
that's not something we there so i think
maybe it needs to have
another form formula to work
to create your budget in the first place
that's just something that i can see as
an issue
would you like me to come back on that
okay
just to perhaps to put it to bed really
um
i think there is there is
you know a question for me about we have
achieved
a balanced budget that has come forward
this year but some of its thanks to
uh uh central government's um
retaining new homes bonus and if we
hadn't had that and that's
quite a you know a skin skin of the the
teeth sort of moments aren't they
because you don't know whether you're
going to get that and how how it's going
to play out
um so should we have been in a very
different scenario
um you know we could be looking at
having to make difficult decisions about
uh costs for the future
um
i i i think it's in some ways sort of
safeguarding of the council's position
if we were to adopt something of this
nature
but
perhaps it's an area i need to to
develop more um to gather you know
uh thoughts and and ideas and and shape
shape it so um
[Music]
happy to just go back to
debates on the
i'm just going to ask emily the
monitoring officer to
advise us
thank you
thank you chair
i just wanted to um highlight to the
committee the um duties that the council
has under the local government and
housing act 1989 section four of that
that act um whereby it is the duty of
the authority to provide the head of
paid service
with appropriate staff and resources to
undertake his duties
which is why the staffing budget is
obviously proposed by the head of paid
service
because it indicates the level of
staffing that he believes is necessary
to deliver the services and strategic
priorities of the council
and so by putting a cap on it or a
restriction in that way
would almost be artificial because the
head of paid service could report to the
authority at any point that he needed
additional
resources and then you would be obliged
to consider those and and approve it if
it was appropriate and relevant and so i
think it's that balance with the
statutory duty that you have in respect
of providing those resources and then
obviously your
fiduciary duties in in respective um
appropriate and proportionate budgeting
thank you
councillor barrett does that um
help i'm not trying to prevent the chief
executive from from uh from providing a
suitable services and i think i think
what i would say is chair that if it's
something that you feel strongly about
perhaps there is another way that that
can be developed perhaps not at this
meeting
if that if that is okay
right
councillor osborne
yeah thank you madam sherman yes
i absolutely agree with the monitoring
officer
um
and i have you know i've experienced
this sort of problem within town council
so
it's not something that
is not known to myself or others that
have been with the town council thank
you
if we've no more questions are we ready
to go with the recommendations
um
chair thank you i i
as referred to earlier i wanted to make
a recommendation um
along
as we we talked about the
the strategic um
the the team
to deliver strategic priorities
um and the um
where that should be monitored as it
goes forward
so i don't know i'm not sure about
wording but just jotted down something
um
that the um we believe that we should
put in place monitoring of progress with
success criteria identified
and i think that's important element to
it so that we know when we're achieving
what we aim setting out to achieve and
this and this would be
referring to the function of the
overview and scrutiny committee yes i
think so well i think that's the only
recommendation yeah no no no but just
certainly it's clear we're talking about
the um scrutiny committee yeah um emily
is there some way we can put that into
a recommendation
um yes i'll just point out that the
performance monitoring and the outcomes
framework obviously is looked at
regularly by the cabinet so there is
some element of
performance monitoring already in place
however the scrutiny committee can of
course choose to look at any aspect of
that that they wish either in isolation
or as the whole program
so it would absolutely be appropriate
for you to make a recommendation
in respect of
either very discreetly looking at how
that particular budget is spent and how
the projects within that budget are
spent
or perhaps sorry how the projects within
that
budget are delivered
um or you could look um asked to look
more generally and ask the cabinet to
report to you on progress with the
strategic priorities overall
what did the committee feel about that
could you just repeat that last sentence
emily we could ask the cabinet to report
yeah so the cabinet have just adopted a
revised outcomes performance framework
um and at the moment there isn't any
plan to bring that into overview and
scrutiny's work plan but you could ask
for the cabinet to report on progress
against those um
outcomes in that performance framework
i think that might be useful chair do
you
counsel barrack does that answer what
you
i think that sounds ideal i mean that
means that that work is taking place and
then we get to to evaluate it there's no
point in duplicating
the that process uh and that sounds you
know
a good use of our time
so we need a proposal
and a second yes our second second
and can we needs that we need to just
be clear about the words that we're
going to
use can we sort of
so after um it's like waving between
officers i think i'm ready to give you
that word thank you
so i think the recommendation is that
the overview and scrutiny committee
receives a report from the cabinet on
progress against the outcome performance
framework
do we need just to say
somewhere how often
we want to receive it
what do you think will be appropriate
emily in terms of frequency
the cabinet will receive quarterly
performance reports so i think that's
probably too frequent for then ons so i
would either say annual or six months
six months
hopefully
i think once you get to annual we've
sort of
drifted a bit haven't we yes you know in
terms of thinking we're already
embarking on a full program anyway
i think six months because then if we
have anything to add it gives a chance
for it to be
heard and adopted
do we
can you advise me do we need to go with
the note in the report first and then
add in the
can you advise me on that anyway yes
chair um i think we need to have a
recommendation first to says that the
overun scrutiny committee notes the
general fund budget 2022-23 and
four-year outlook
and then that the second recommendation
is let me hope i got this right that the
overview and scrutiny committee receives
a report from cabinet on the outcomes of
the performance freight framework on a
six-month basis
is that
that sounds fine so with the note in the
um
we will be noting the notes in the
general fund the general fund
um
are we going to an electronic vote for
that
yes chair um we can if you are happy for
just having read them out we can just
yeah as the committee's officer uh read
out and you can go to a vote now which
beth will now yeah is everybody like to
vote um
the vote is now in progress
councillor was one can i take your vote
verbally please
thank you
i haven't i haven't switched in sorry
bethany sign for it i killed her
thank you chair that's four votes for
that's unanimous
thank you
that concludes this item
uh i want to thank everybody that was
here for the first item but i presume
he's staying for the second as well
so
can i um
go down the agenda to item seven
and this is the vos stroke 21 stroke
zero two draft housing revenue account
hra and four year outlook and councillor
barrett and
and catherine will be presenting this
item thank you very much
thank you jim um
this is the
report to over in scrutiny regarding the
housing revenue account
recommendation is 3.1
whether the committee has any
recommendations to take to full
to cabinet on the 7th and then obviously
full council
as you can see
the quarter two um
provision within the uh document shows
that there is a 499
deficit
out turn in the account this is mainly
due to the
um
extra spending
from the uh
housing
and building services
which i think is covered in in the
report
i think this is a combination of factors
which possibly you need to look at
obviously covid has had a significant
increase
in getting jobs done
there's a lot of cost pressures
material pressures uh this is generally
throughout the whole of the building
services
um the other pressure which
we do come up against is um
the fact that we're in
competing for labour in a very
competitive hot market
um and sometimes we're probably not as
competitive which means that we then
have to go out to
um
to subcontract i think the old pink
notices which we never used to issue
much are now being issued regularly
so
that has caused but this has been
rectified within the
um
budget so there's a more realistic
budget being put forward you'll see a 15
increase
which still leaves a surplus of 486 i
think that a more updated surplus is
slightly more favorable as well in the
latest figures i've seen
but generally the uh position on the um
hra is is in a good shape
we are also recommending um
we have a table which you will see of
potential increases in council
house rents
we are able to go to cpi plus one
um and uh this hasn't been obviously
decided yet but this will be decided at
cabinet but i think the recommendation
will be to use cpi plus one to bring
that in line
um
in previous years um there has been a uh
reduction in rates of one percent over a
number of years
which meant the whole rental base was
was not really kept pace
and at the end of the day we want to be
able to provide our
tenants with the best possible quality
of housing
also you'll see the the capital program
there's a lot set aside
for improvements
and those improvements are not just
improvements for
kitchens and things but they are
actually also hopefully improvements in
terms of
heating
insulation and various other areas but
i'm sure um
the ad will be able to go through that
with you in more detail
so that gives you that so the
recommendation as before you
um
obviously he's 3.1 and i put that to you
and also at catherine um we'll go
through the slides now
with the uh various
options no oh we haven't got slides
oh behind on that one then oh we haven't
got slides on hra right okay
sorry so
i'll go back to you manager but there's
uh 3.1
sorry about that i thought we were
did you did you want to add to that
catherine please
no i don't think there's too much to add
to that thank you chair um i think the
this is an area that's sort of
reasonably self-contained it's obviously
a smaller area than the general fund had
hence not we didn't feel the need to do
a presentation and i think all the
information is in your report so just
happen to open up for questions thank
you
okay members we'll go straight to
questions then please
councillor barrett
thank you could i start by just asking
um
the assistant director if he would be
able to talk to us about the
that um overspend in building services
it was quite a significant
amount
and uh and
and perhaps see what what you feel is
attributable to
thank you chair thank you councillor for
the question um
i think it's it's a reality that since
um 2017 when
um the council's made a decision to
bring in house that the building
services function um that we've faced
ongoing challenges in the delivery of
that service for for a variety of
reasons most recently obviously that the
covered impacts and the impacts on on
not being able to access tennis homes
for example there has been a huge amount
of work done in that service over the
past
uh five years to to remedy and improve
the overall performance of that that
team
i'm pleased to say that we are seeing
real green shoots in terms of of the
progress that's been made and i'll come
on to talk about some of the examples of
of how we we're trying to to generate
even greater values of money
the reality is that um as a landlord of
social housing stock local authority
housing stock the building services
function will always cost
money
i think the purpose of of me being here
and colleagues is to ensure that in
terms of value for money
we provide a value for money service and
obviously ensure that uh that the cost
is is minimized wherever wherever
possible
talking to our hra business plan
consultant we use an external consultant
to look at the 30-year plan and look at
our income and expenditure
just as a footnote and this might help
members
conscious of the numbers but
typically as an average in the sector
the average cost of staffing supervision
management and carrying out day-to-day
repairs to a a social housing home is
approximately on average two thousand
four hundred per property per year um
actually baby suffix average is running
at approximately 2100 per property per
year so you can see that already we are
very lean and efficient in the way that
we run the housing service um in
comparison to the average some some 300
pounds per per property
i think it's also important to note in
terms of that value for money question
um that in
baber alone we've acquired or built more
than 219 properties um over the past
four to five years
and as such obviously managing more
stock you would expect there to be more
staff to collect the rent and and to
maintain those those properties actually
we haven't seen those increases and and
that has been absorbed within our
existing uh
our existing staffing base which again
improves on that that efficiency
if i could come on back to
building services
what what has become apparent and more
so as part of the budget setting process
for this year because i'm pleased to say
we've got a new building services
corporate manager in post and a new hra
finance business partner that both
joined um in those roles um over the
last six months we've been able to do a
fundamental review of all expenditure
over the last uh six six years
and what that's identified is
year-on-year unfortunately budgets have
been set unrealistically hence the
organization and the team and and then
in terms of delivering the out turn
reports we've always been up against it
in terms of uh of of delivering or not
on a perhaps a budget that is
unrealistic now i know for
members and and personally for myself as
well
budgets have to be realistic um they
they clearly can't be um extortionate
and can't be excessive in in terms of of
the budget set but likewise they can't
be uh undervalued and and hence an
adverse variants um on a regular basis
and i genuinely believe that work that
uh finance and and building services
have done in recent weeks and months
will ensure that for the 22 23 budget is
set at a more risk more realistic
achievable and value for money level
just in terms of why you're looking at
in terms of a budget a level of
increased cost and just to provide you
with some more detail conscious that
we're looking at 15
increase in the budget for 22.23
some of the reasons for these additional
costs in addition to that review of
budget setting is the cost of hvo which
all of our fleet will be moving to over
the course of 22 23 which which is
obviously more expensive than than
traditional diesel fuel costs
we're also providing much more
additional training to our trades team
in order to
reduce our dependency on subcontractors
um and council barrett um mentioned the
the dependency on subcontractors what
we've identified is there are certain
skills certain attributes that if we can
upskill our existing workforce we can
reduce our dependency on on
subcontractors and for example they
might be around upvc uh window and door
repairs
as an example or
gaining entry to properties and
preventing damage to to doors
etc
we've also seen the cost of materials
rise and and and councilor barrett
mentioned it and and
everyone in the industry is is facing
this this challenge
we've seen a bag of cement rise by more
than 40 percent uh a a a piece of wood
rise by more than 40 whilst the overall
basket of materials
has generally risen by more than 15
we do work with one main material
supplier travis perkins as our main
material contractor and we do monitor
that basket of materials
regularly at month to month to to look
at where
where those prices are going and we
obviously evaluate using different
materials where appropriate
as you've mentioned on the general fund
there is naturally the assumption that
their staffing costs will increase
whether that be increments or whether
that be cost of living rises
and then this year uh as planned
we will be looking to replace our
existing fleet vehicles because they've
come to the end of their natural life in
terms of of existing leases and there
are costs associated that both with the
lease both we've removing the sign
writing from existing vehicles before we
give them back to the lease company uh
racking uh etcetera etcetera whilst was
carrying out those two to the new
vehicles
if i could just take time
to just
evidence and and provides um over
scrutiny with with some examples of of
actually how we're trying to minimize
those costs going forward
um we're seeing and looking to see uh
efficiencies generated by the use of
technology through our workforce
so that's scheduling software net which
now
in in recent weeks and the last couple
of months has prevented the need for
uh jobs that are reported into our
customer access point to be passed to
the back office to then schedule that
can be done at the front end now as a
role of new technology we've introduced
in software
we're also about to introduce new
management void management software
which we believe will reduce
the overall cost on managing voids
and we're seeing improvements made in in
apportioning capital and revenue costs
where where appropriate as well as
around that effective management of
materials
as well
hopefully that provides some some
narrative as to why we've seen
traditionally an adverse variance on
building services and why we're
proposing this new budget to be more
realistic uh going forward
thank you gavin
yeah i suppose you know i don't
understand kovitz having a big impact in
this but the previous year was also a
lockdown year
and i don't know whether that year was
also
significantly impacted in this way
um
and why perhaps it wasn't assumed that
the this following year would be would
be the same
i'm not sure if catherine can you
comment on previous years or gavin
gavin
thank you um
in terms of the year 2019 2020
we did see the adverse variants fall
dramatically because we weren't able to
carry out as much work what we've faced
as well as the industry
are long periods of of the last two
years when actually our workforce
haven't been able to carry out the work
that they're trained qualified and able
to do and during those lock down periods
as you recall actually we redeployed our
building services staff to just
emergencies but also cleaning of
sheltered housing schemes um and
maintaining our temporary housing stock
so that we could get the throat for the
the throughput of of people from from
hotels um into temporary accommodation
um and then into um and then into our
homes um
as a result of of of some of those lock
downs and as a result of um
also prohibiting tenants from from
reporting repairs what we've seen both
us locally and and nationally and
regionally is this pent-up demand that's
been caused by people unable to report
repairs have those repairs carried out
and and also i think the reality that
we'd all agree with in that
we've all spent so much more time at
home so we've we've noticed those those
perhaps repairs that might go unnoticed
or we've been using our homes that much
more than we would do traditionally in
in traditional terms so we are playing
catch up and as a result of that in in
terms of last year's or this current
year's adverse variants which will come
to a closing in march in terms of 21 22
we have had to rely on additional
subcontractors to supplement our
workforce and supplement that work
and and it's clearly a balancing act
because
by employing subcontractors you you
create more cost um but but not by
employing those those subcontractors you
face disrepair claims where potentially
there's compensation due to tenants um
or void times
become protracted
people are sitting in temporary
accommodation longer or members would be
questioning the performance and and
challenging the length of time that that
properties remain empty so so it is
continuously a balancing act
and what one that we we we try and do
most effectively one of the benefits of
using subcontractors is we use a
schedule of rates um and and thus we
have a fixed price for a fixed type of
repair so we know what our costs will be
going into that work
thank you gavin
have we got any more questions from
councillor osborne
thank you madam chairman um i'm just um
looking at um
4.7
under the co bed and
up to 4.9
and the average cost of social housing
um
first of all i'm very pleased to see
that um
you have not uh
evicted it or taken any uh once it's on
people that have either fallen in
deficit or has a problem uh from the
coved situation so i'm very pleased to
see that however what i would like to
know is you put down the average cost of
from social housing
is is that part
on that social housing
difficult for me to explain but
um
anti-social behaviour does that reflect
on the on the loss of or extra work
involved and
what do you how do you put that amount
down
i have a couple of other questions but
i'll wait for that one
thank you chair thank you councillor
osborne for the for the question um
the reality is that we have um generic
housing officers that um
manage the council tendencies that that
that we have we do have a specialist
income team and that income team are
clearly going to be devoted to uh
gaining gaining income that that we all
need to to spend in the hra
the more generic housing officer
function um will be a mixture of of
duties so that can be around um tenancy
changes it can be around asb anti-social
behavior it can also be around support
and attendance so where perhaps the
tenant has found difficulties um gaining
the support of the housing officer to
signpost them to to to other agencies
the reality is that that
all of that work is absorbed within that
team so we don't break down the cost of
anti-social behavior
to us as a landlord differently to to to
managing that that wider housing
management function
so i can't give you
an estimate as to to the cost of of
managing asb
um what i can point to is that through
our consultation on the hra business
plan uh during the latter half of of
last year we know that our tenants who
who responded in their droves actually
didn't prioritize asb as being one of
the contributory factors as to
how they live their satisfaction of the
landlord service or their satisfaction
of the neighborhoods that they they live
in they prioritize more
around cleanliness car parking um
et cetera so we don't see that we've got
significant problem with asb
over the past 12 months what we have
been doing
in conjunction with the whole
organization across the board
is taking the learning from the the
recent stella marist report
and looking at the way that we deliver
anti-social behavior services across the
organization
and that's included an action plan and
new ways of working so an example of
that is a housing officer carrying out a
risk assessment based on the level of
risk to the
alleged uh victim so that we can manage
prioritized cases and look to resolve
those cases where the highest risk is
would you like to continue with
counselors
thank you uh thank you gavin and
i do appreciate all the work you've
carried out over the years as
i've been an older member
i do know what you've done so thank you
but
the other concern i've got is you put
down other income
and no no income has been received from
the last two years for
recovering legal costs
um
you know you've reduced it but um
does this impact on on
on the costs that you're actually having
to by not getting this back
i mean weber are going to be
responsible for paying the uh
paying that monies out if if as we said
we're talking about
in sudbury i can definitely say that um
anti-social behavior has cost a lot of a
lot of money particularly in in areas
where there's been fires and
unfortunately weber have had to um take
the
take that hit for that
and the other question was
can you can you tell me what the
renewable heat sources has done to help
for
the council in terms of the renewable
heat incentive
um and what type of heating are you
putting in as renewable heat thank you
thank you madam chairman
thank you chair thank you council
osborne um hopefully i've i've
understood the question apologies if i
haven't i'm happy to uh for you to
to advise me again
in terms of other income
what that's referring to
in terms of recovering legal costs yes
there will naturally be times when we
look to
generate additional incomes or or ensure
that the cost of our service is
efficient so for example
um
where a tenant leaves their property and
we go into the property at the point of
void and find that there's been
significant tenant damage
we would look to go through and follow a
process where recharges are charged to
that tenant that was outgoing uh for the
cost of any damage that they have caused
naturally there will be a process in
which we follow to try and recover those
monies
and the decision has to be made at a
certain point as to whether or not we
are going to to to look at legal action
to recover those monies or not um in the
in this example of asb we would clearly
where asb
has been the cause of damage uh to to
homes
we would work with the police
and work with other agencies to identify
um that the perpetrator and if criminal
proceedings are being bought against
that individual uh look to to recover uh
damages from them uh for the cost of any
damage that they've caused um naturally
where asb might be that the contributory
factor would typically depending on the
the amount of work uh be looking at an
insurance claim
and using our insurance provision to to
fund uh to fund that work
in terms of um
renewable heat incentives this is
fundamentally great work done by
colleagues within the building services
team who continuously um and
historically have looked at where they
can
obtain additional grants or additional
benefits by uh installing the most
energy efficient uh uh heating to
existing council homes
and the renewable heat incentive
has been a long-standing uh benefit to
us um by putting in airsource heat pumps
and we continue to have a program of
installing sc s or heat pumps wherever
possible and hinge the report mentions
uh
the numbers of heat pumps installed
clearly going forward what we do know is
that significant investment will be
required in our existing stock to meet
the aspirations of the government
whether that be
all social housing being epcc
by 2030
some some eight years away
or
our ambitions to be carbon zero
within our social housing stop by by
2050
and we are actively working with the
energy saving trust
and we are actively working with
colleagues across the county
to ensure that we're well placed to
attract
any grant monies that are available
through for example the social housing
decarbonisation program
so that the the total burden the total
cost isn't isn't having to be burdened
by by tenants but actually we receive as
much grant um as possible
another question councillor osborne
thank you madam chairman um also i'm i'm
pleased to uh
please to see that um
temporary housing
for for
either homeless or uh
areas where they
haven't been able to get a property
and completely and
the
reason for that is that obviously hotels
etc do
cost a lot a lot of money to to house
these unfortunate
residents
do we in fact
have a stock
where we would not have to be able to
use uh
hotels et cetera i mean i know there's
been a lot of work carried out on this
and
it it's definitely improved it so does
your figures show that um
the improvement in um
uh getting housing for
a social housing for re for residents or
homelessness um
that has that been a benefit to to buda
itself and
in terms of the budget thank you
thank you council osborne um i think
where the the budget paper is referring
to is um hra assets that are owned by
the hra uh but are being used for the
purposes of providing temporary
accommodation to those that are homeless
and we continually as officers look at
our stock profile
look at the opportunities which lend
themselves to uh using uh accommodation
for
for different uh reasons and different
priorities
there's there's always going to be a
balancing act between
those on the housing register and those
in most need
but for example some of our stock
depending on the type of property its
location our long-term plans for for
that property we might work with the
temporary accommodation team and use it
as temporary accommodation
we have got units that we use for
domestic abuse and being able to
house victims of domestic abuse at short
notice
and we also work with suffolk county
council
to identify properties that we could
lease to the county
for the provision of children young
people or adult and community services
where for example
a property might be uh at least to to
enable care leavers to uh to
to to enjoy their own independent
accommodation so um our stock is used in
in for a different variety of different
purposes um
coming to to temporary accommodation and
the work of the the homelessness team
which doesn't form uh the hra per se and
it's a general fund function um much of
the work that we've done over the past
two years is to obviously mitigate the
the the requirements of everyone in
and the huge influx of people that were
homeless as a result of covid whilst
there was a dependency on hotels
initially actually we've been able to
reduce that yes we do from time to time
use bed and breakfast accommodation in
ipswich where necessary but we always
use that as a last resort
and across our temporary accommodation
asset base we've got more than 90
properties that we use for temporary
accommodation across the two councils
they will be a mixture of hra assets
they'll also be a mixture of general
fund assets
and for example
we also lease properties from for
example in hadley at the local church
and you'll be aware that in in recent
years we've also purchased new
accommodations such as the foyer in in
stone market and and we we're flexible
in that temporary accommodation is used
across the two councils it's not
designated to to toba homeless or
mid-suffolk homeless it's about making
best use of the accommodation that we've
got
and the work that we've been doing with
um d-luck the department of um leveling
up homes and communities
we've been able to evidence that
actually the length of time people are
staying in bed and breakfast
accommodation is is continuing to reduce
um and i'm pleased to say uh be less
than the government targets in terms of
for example a family being bed and
breakfast for for no more than six weeks
and we're achieving those targets uh on
an ongoing basis
yes
yeah thank you for that gavin i'm very
appreciative of of all of that you've
done
but
the thousand dollar question is
is that making a budget
a loss not a loss but
we're not using so much money as we used
to on on those sort of properties where
we've had to have bed and breakfast so
if that is the case i'm very pleased um
i'd just like to thank you again for
your your answers for those and now i'll
possibly um might get it in the neck
from the cabinet member for housing
thank you
did the cabinet member for housing wish
to respond to that
thank you madam chairman no i won't
respond to that but he's absolutely
right um i was going to provide an
answer to that but the ads provided more
than an adequate comprehensive response
to those questions thank you very much
madam jen
any more questions by the committee
council
um yes thank you
um with the prospect of rising fuel
bills
um
one of the best ways to ensure that
fuel bills are reduced as far as they
can is to insulate houses
and i'm sure we're all aware that
caroline lucas
is frequently asking that central
government feed down to local
governments to local authorities and
funds to do that to make it possible um
i i suppose i'm a bit concerned about
i'm really pleased to see that we're
fitting so many air source heat pumps
and i would hope that they are in the
relatively modern housing stock that we
have
because to be fitting an air source heat
pump into an old house um
is perhaps not the best use of funds
having said all of that you don't
insulate a house overnight so it takes
time and it takes money
and we know that it it's going to cost
within the region of millions to
retrofit all of our housing stock to a
standard which we would like to see so
my question really is
i see that we've got 500k a year to do
that
is the assumption that 500k a year
is sufficient a correct assumption or
should we be looking at actually putting
more money into the budget to
insulate to retrofit and where necessary
to demolish because sometimes you can
spend a disproportionate amount of money
retrofitting where you'd have been
better to have just demolished and
started again
did you manage to unpick a question in
that
thanks
gavin do you want to respond to that
yeah thank you chair um
firstly um
took the question and totally agree with
with the points um made
um in relation to the report and and
it's my apology uh 4.21 um environmental
improvements
that is in our retrofit program that
isn't necessarily our external wall
insulation program or anything of the
like
apologies in terms of of the header but
that's
more
lending itself to possibly increase
biodiversity or
estate improvement to to overall improve
the the environment um the planned
maintenance uh header of which budget
for for forthcoming years is more than
six million is where you would see um
that investment in in some of the
schemes that that the council has has
described external wall insulation uh
and the alike um what we do know is
we've been carrying out a huge amount of
work over the past 12 months alongside
the energy saving trust a well-respected
and well-regarded
entity
and what we have now is a stock profile
of each and every individual property
made up on more than 80 different uh
energy ratings or denominators
and what that's enabling us to do is
better program uh better prioritize
and better manage in terms of a cost
envelope the amount of investment that
we're going to have to spend on existing
homes as we bring forward the hra
business plan over the next few few
months that's where
if you've been in any of the briefings
that i've presented
where cabinet will have difficult
decisions to make because clearly there
is a finite amount of income within the
hra and here you're looking at a budget
and looking at a potential increase in
in terms of rents
and that money will be spent on a
variety of different causes uh for which
over the forth coming years i think
we're going to see more and more
pressure in terms of the balance between
building new homes versus retrofitting
and improving the existing homes and
that's where cabinets rightfully have a
decision to make in terms of here's the
amount of money we've got where do we
best spend and utilise those funds
solar
john osborne you wanted to make a
comment there yeah thanks madam chairman
um i think obviously retrofitting is
always it's really very much part of the
discussions that we have on a regular
basis i think coming forward is the
design guide which will be coming to um
cabinet and then on to council
in later spring that will set out our
aspirations again we're financially
viable
um
because we need to bear in mind that
it's a balance between retrofitting and
providing homes for much you know where
they're much needed
i think it's realistic to say that there
is no way we will be able to retrofit
every single one of our properties it
would just be not financially viable
considering the age that they are but um
to date we have spent uh over eight
hundred thousand on heating upgrades
we've spent over nearly over seven
hundred and seventy thousand on
installation improvements which you
alluded to earlier council
and eight over 821 um on environmental
improvements so very much we are already
spending money in those areas and will
continue to do so but at the same time
as cabinet member for housing i will
point out that we also need to be able
to provide housing for people that are
in much need a place to call their home
thank you madam chairman thank you
councillor osborne
i've got one question
um
and um i'm going to address it to
catherine actually
i'm not sure whether i shouldn't have
asked it in the in the previous
presentation but it's about the um
the debt that is incurred by
our residents um
and so given the different systems
across the council and the shared
revenue partnership in relation to the
monetary transactions we have with our
residents
how realistic it would be
how realistic it would it be
to have a system that keeps a
record per resident of money's paid and
money's owed
in one sort of
central system
because i understand at the moment it's
it's dealt with by two different systems
council tax and and rent arrears
thank you
i think potentially a resident could
come into contact with several different
areas of of the council you know they
might be a tenant so they could they
could have a rent that they owe us they
would equally have council tax that they
owe us as well
um
i think our ambition certainly would be
that we would want to have that one view
of a resident in terms of their contact
with you know with the council but
unfortunately we're not there at the
moment we have got different uh software
systems that don't necessarily
talk to each other
um and so i think this is this is quite
a major project in terms of getting that
that view um and i think uh our
assistant director for for customers
that's certainly a an ambition
again i think it's what's affordable
again and can we get to that place but i
know there are lots of conversations
about our data and how we can better
understand and share our data and and
perhaps get to the point you know where
we have that one view of a resident um
which is um unfortunately we can't at
the moment um do that but yes certainly
would share the ambition to be able to
do that from our residents perspective
you know so they just come to us and we
have that picture of exactly what
which areas of our services that you
know they have been in contact with and
continue to be
gavin i'll come back to you councillor
osborne had her hand up first uh
councillor john osborne thank you all
right thank you madam chairman um
catherine is absolutely right but also
in in addition to that i think we're
restricted by government regulations
insomuchas
when um the rent
benefit entitlement is provided it's on
a notification when council tax benefit
notifica is benefit is advised that's
also on a notification at the moment
regulations do not permit if i think i'm
right in saying this those two
notifications to be put together as one
outstanding debt if you like certainly
we can look at it and i'm not sure if
catherine and
gavin have got anything to add to this
we can look at it as a project in the
future to see how that we can overcome
that but i think at the moment it
wouldn't be possible in line with the
regulations that are in place
thank you
thank you chair um just listening to the
to the conversation and trying to
understand um a little bit more about
the context of your question
i think whilst the systems don't um
allow for for that joined up approach
that you describe um we do have um
employee tenancy support officers that
work with 10 tenants and it's 10-year
blind as well so it's not just council
housing tenants can be private tenants
as well for example um and they do have
a direct relationship with the shared
revenues and benefits partnership as
they do also with department of work and
pensions in relation to universal credit
and i think the point that you were
referring to is about chasing that pound
and if there are multiple asks on on
that pound um and and the individual's
got a finite amount of income um is
there a better way of everyone getting
getting
the income um that they rightfully
owed so we do work actively with them
obviously through the use of
discretionary housing payments as well
uh to to maximize the income
coming into to people's
households
councillor john osborne
yeah if i could just add to that we
actually now have a system called rent
source that we use on a regular basis
which identifies those
um
residents that are liable to get into
rent arrears and as the ads um alluded
to we then point them in the direction
of support for that but it's all about
early intervention it's about prevention
rather than cure
well can i just say um thank you to um
before we go into debate uh thank you to
council barrett and catherine for their
report and thank you also to gavin and
his team for all the hard work that's
gone on
recognising that the last 18 months have
been very difficult and especially
for housing and all that goes with that
so thank you very much
so now opening up the debate to members
i would like to
start the debate
i'll start this one madame chef thank
you although it's it's not really any
uh significant um
position but
i'm happy with
as i see
the answers that i've got i've got back
from my questions and those are my
colleagues um
i now know of work and situations over
our offices are under going in in
keeping our costs to a minimum
therefore giving our financial officers
some solace so
um
if that is kept as it is i'm sure we
will improve our our
ability to improve our
how hra accounts and ensure that the
housing stock will increase and the only
way to do it obviously
is to
keep our costs to a minimum
and hopefully get
the grants where they attend uh
come from uh casserys
thank you man of children
councillor barrett thank you
thank you very much um well
as i examine the sort of the situation
and building services a little bit more
i just
would would conclude that i'm pleased to
to hear about the um
the increased sort of software that will
enable better planning work better
utilization of those skilled trades
people and so on that sounds sounds good
moving towards you know better
management overall and which can only be
good to increa control costs
um
i suppose what we
would want to see there for then is less
use of sub subcontractors in the future
um and um i guess that that's really the
conclusion that
that um by
having your your review with your your
new managers to to look at what what's
realistic and what what the
in-house can deliver
then hopefully you are then in that
position where you are
really cutting down on the the the
subcontractors uh use so
i don't know whether that's something we
will then put into our our
recommendations and i'm not quite clear
whether with that
where that if that goes through to any
recommendations so perhaps
the report is just for noting
okay if you wish to add a further
recommendation
um
well i'm getting nods from
gavin about less sub cracks of
subbies so um so that's gavin do you
want to come in on that
thank you
i think what we could do through the
development of the quarterly out turn
report is provide
some evidence through that report as to
the use of external subcontractors and
possibly profiling
where we are using subcontractors and
for what reasons and and overall
the sort of trajectory really of of use
of subcontractors if that would help
would
would that be helpful for as a committee
for us to have an say an information
bulletin on that
i mean how does
if we
propose that say
an information bulletin
have we got any ideas how frequently
that ought to be
it's a valid point but i don't think we
should get too hung up on the use of
subcontractors if they remain within the
budget that's set
because at the end of the day
in times past the use of subcontractors
on pink tickets was the norm and that's
how work was carried out
um so i think uh i think what what you
should be really looking at as
far as i can see is that not that
subcontractors per se are bad
and shouldn't be used it's thus that you
want to be contained within your budget
delivering for your residence so i think
um
the use of subcontractors
obviously when you have your own
workforce wants to be reduced but it's
not something that is bad because as
gavin has pointed out
so those subcontractors have specialist
skills which we don't have and uh you
need to employ them so it's it's
i think
the overall position of the council is
is it within the budget that's said and
is it delivering
what is required i
is is a response to a tenant's call
handled fairly quickly as opposed to
being delayed probably more important
i'd thought to the tenant rather than
whether it's a subcontractor they don't
care
but but basically they want to get that
repair carried out quickly
counselor osborne
thank you madam chairman yeah i
absolutely agree with council about and
i was going to raise the same concerns
what we need to be careful of is that we
need we have a standard that we need to
keep to and if we get to a situation
where officers feel they're being
monitored far too much on the number of
contractors that are being used then
it's only um
natural that they will be reluctant to
use those contractors and and then the
standard of work may uh decrease and we
may not be able to provide those
specialized services that we currently
do absolutely agree we need to monitor
the use of contractors i'm doing that
when i have my monthly meetings all the
time so
that is a piece of work that's already
being done however if scrutiny would
like us to report on it would i i could
suggest that we go down the same routes
we've suggested with the
during the general budget that it can be
part of the quarterly monitoring report
that that would make sense to tighten
wouldn't it
can we put some um well
anymore
i mean we're still in debate
okay
well i suppose um i would just like to
say um 11.6 is is good and positive that
surveyors have been studying for this
retrofit coordinators diploma
and training is always good
um
and i suppose i would just sort of
wonder whether i'm sure gavin that you
do keep an eye on any other training
courses that might be there
in terms of retrofitting and just to say
again that any money we spend
on heating our houses
unless they're insulated
is
not money well spent really so i take
councillor jan osborne's point that
clearly we're not going to be able to
retrofit every house in our housing
stock but money that goes into heating
houses that aren't insulated and it
doesn't necessarily have to be cladding
um you know just extra loft insulation
you don't need me to tell you your job
but money that's going into houses that
aren't insulated is potentially not a
good use of our funds
thank you that's all
i was just going to add to the
debate about
the subcontractors i think if i was
somebody
waiting for a repair to do to be done
i i would be grateful for whoever came
and
i would want the repair to be dealt with
speedily whether they were a
subcontractor or employed by the council
so um probably i disagree a bit okay it
doesn't um
concern me as much but if we if we would
like
an
additional um
piece to the
report that we were talking about
council barack was your idea
your proposal i
i'm not against subcontractors but i
think um and there is a case obviously
there's a case for uh using
subcontractors isn't there um without a
doubt um but
shouldn't they be within the anticipated
costs for the year
and not beyond that
that's that's the point isn't it they
should be anticipated and understood and
sort of contained contained to a degree
and so that's where
where we are because we're examining
this overspend that wasn't anticipated
um i'm just keen that that
that um
we don't get into an overspend really uh
that's where where we we haven't
anticipated the use of subcontractors we
do anticipate the use of them so we
should be able to build that into a
future budget
any more comments by the committee
in debate
are we ready to um make the
recommendations
yeah
can the governance officer
um read out
the recommendation
do we want to take what character did we
actually have a second for this
recommendation oh sorry we didn't
all right
right chair so i have a 1.1 that the
overview and scrutiny committee notes
the housing revenue account 2022-23
and four-year outlook
and that the overu and scrutiny
committee recommends that an information
that information about the use of
subcontractors be included in the
quarterly performance monitoring string
report
everybody
happy with that are members happy with
that recommendation yes
electronic vote please the governance
officer thank you chair debate is now in
progress
council russell might take you back
verbally please
thank you chad that's four votes for and
that's unanimous
thank you
so that brings us to the end of um
this part of the meeting and i just want
to thank all the officers and
the two cabinet members for
providing us with a very good
presentation and for the very hard work
that goes into all these reports that we
receive
and so i'm going now on to the rest of
the agenda which is the forthcoming
decision list
right
any
comments
that
members may have on the fourth community
decision list
any comments on the forthcoming
decisions list it was quite lengthy
actually
it's a lot to read
anybody
any comments
okay
well it depends how much you print off
actually it goes on forever
it does go on a long way so i had a look
at it some of it we've already covered
one we've already covered in that
previous recommendation you made
councilor barrett
that's already covered so i was happy
with that
thank you
no more comments then the forthcoming
decision list is for noting
so which takes us to item nine
which is the
work plan
for babera overview and scrutiny
committee
any comments that members would like to
make
any suggestions actually i think is
if members would like to make any
suggestions that need to be considered
for the work plan
i i think
i think i i would be interested in
looking at um
the
um accommodation these the accommodation
here at endeavour house and
and
whether we
do
give up some some office space or
on a permanent basis or whether there is
there is a case for
holding fire on that
um
yes
yeah yeah
is that possible to uh
only
chair there's a report coming to um the
cabinet meeting on the 7th of february
to have a look at the accommodation and
agile strategy
specifically in relation to
accommodation at an at endeavour house
so unless you called an additional
meeting of this committee
there's not the opportunity for
pre-scrutiny at this stage
and then once the decision is made
then there's no recourse to overview and
scrutiny either
following the decision the only option
is um the call-in process and the
committee would need to um believe that
there'd been some error with the process
okay so it's not straightforward
thank you
anything anything else that members may
wish to
to suggest councillor osborne
not really a suggestion madam chairman
um
it's it's a question of this the joint
working between mid-suffolk and
ourselves i take it um for clarification
that there are a number of issues that
are coming up which will be joined
so
i i can't see any problems with um with
what we're going to do as a as a as our
own ovn scrutiny
meeting
thank you
however i think if we felt strongly
about something we could arrange a
separate and independent
baby
which might be helpful anyway
i think it's
without any um
with the greatest respect i do find that
our overview and scrutiny
work that babadoo
does take on a different a different um
look when we've got joint meeting with
mid suffolk
and um
it does tend to throw some of our
decisions
out the
window thank you
i used to can i just go back council
robert are you suggesting that we have
more
independent
meetings for baber
um
on one particular issues which are um
very important to to baba and to
scrutinize uh braber's uh works
yes i i think we should um
diversify and make sure that we don't um
getting getting
bogged down with mid-south at work thank
you
how would we
manage that effectively then only
thank you chair so um at the moment you
have a joint by default approach so the
meetings are um intended to be joint but
we always hold separate meeting dates in
the diary so you've always got the
option to actually
say we're not going to meet jointly in
any particular month and we're going to
meet separately instead
another option that i've been discussing
with the chairs of the two overview and
scrutiny committees
is to hold
meetings rather than joint meetings
and so what that means is that if either
of the committees are in core eight it
doesn't impact on the other committee
being able to proceed
but also that either committee could
have additional single council business
on the same agenda and therefore you
would just continue your meeting and the
other council would leave for that that
portion of the meeting so it gives you a
bit more flexibility
about including single council
items on your meeting agenda without
hold having to hold an entirely separate
meeting
does that
does that
um
jay if i may at the moment uh you have
uh formal joint meetings so
um there's a requirement for um the
meeting to be correct from both
committees um and you are only able to
consider joint items at those meetings
so i think that i think there is a
possible i think i'd like further
discussion with you emily about that
because i think there are times i mean
the two councils totally different
and sometimes it's
counsellor
gold
can i just clarify their memory with you
so if we go to simultaneous meetings
that it will take the place of the joint
meetings
so they will be called simultaneous
there'd be no requirement for each
individual council to be caught
necessarily
and we could split off if there's any
individual items at the end so we would
have simultaneously instead of
joint yeah yes that's exactly right um
and for all intents and purposes it
would feel like a joint meeting because
you would be debating items together and
you'd hear the same presentation the
difference is is because they are two
sovereign meetings you would have to
vote separately
and things like apologies would be
separate and minutes would be separate
that that kind of thing
would that have resource implications
then for the governance officers and the
and the supporting
officers
um the only um slight difference would
be two sets of minutes would need to be
produced um but again you know the bulk
of the minute taking which is the record
of the debate and the questioning would
be the same because that would be done
jointly so it would just be that there
would be two physical sets of of minutes
rather than a single set of joint
minutes uh which you have at the moment
any
and if we if both councils had um the
need for a breakout meeting we if we
both had our own individual items to
discuss would that give us a resource
issue in that there's only one council
chamber would it be okay for one council
to go somewhere else
um in that case what we tend to do
this is similar to when we were
operating simultaneous cabinet meetings
if you recall
those and what we tended to do there
were would be that if one if both
councils had single council items one
council would do it at the start of the
meeting and then the other council
members would join
then we would move into the joint
business and then the other council
would do their single item at the start
so it kind of top entails the joint part
of the meeting it sounds complex and it
can be a bit unwieldy but when you get
into the swing of it it makes sense in
it and it runs quite smoothly actually
no
but i will actually
speak with you and see what we can i
mean i i want us to
come up with ideas as well
for discussion
we're trying to get away from this
standard programme that goes
is repeated year after year
and
in previous meetings we've recognized
that there's only two essential in great
you know parts of the work plan that
we're legally required to do which is
the budget and the community safety
partnership
so we have got that choice to be a bit
more flexible and a bit more responsive
and emily has had discussions with both
chairs about that
i just want to thank everybody that's
come today thank you committee for that
was a long session and i think it was a
very useful
discussion
councillor osborne
thank you madam chair i'd just like to
say thank you to you for for cheering at
this meeting and the officers that were
here too absolutely thank you very much
i know i'd like just to
thank bethany
that was just um
about two two meetings within a short
period of time and it is really
it's hard work doing this committee so
thank you very much bethany and abel is
supported by henriette
thank you i declare the meeting closed
you